bien
[Music
] greets héctor mejía with
headlines for today thursday october 22
the clark county school district board of directors
plans to discuss
the transition to hybrid education at
a meeting scheduled for today at
5 pm however  the vote will
take place until November 12
because they will wait to discuss this
change with the community this would be the
first step for students and
teachers to return to the classroom
the health district for while it will give
more recent information related to
the cases  of coronavirus in the county
on the other hand early voting continues
around the valley yesterday there
were a total of 30,000 people who
exercised their right in
clark county this adds up to 140 thousand so far
since the first day of voting which
began on saturday has until  on
October 30 to vote early in person
cannot return their ballot by mail
before official Election Day on
which is November 3,
several riders players were
placed in isolation after being
exposed to the coronavirus yesterday they
notified that 3 round belonged to the
covite list hours later the
coach announced that his entire
offensive line had gone home at the
end  practice while the
team prepares with a plan for the
game this Sunday
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have clear skies with a
maximum of 90 degrees for today
however the temperatures will drop and
the winds will return for the
weekend  Have a nice day and maybe I
am Héctor Mejía and this was your brief
information on teaching in Spanish
[Music]